fighter power of gaza hates gold i am
hella mark harley and we are going to
start off this episode right off the bat
addressing the controversy that many of
you have already probably become aware
of
yesterday on the fighter and the kid i
showed a clip of andrew tate that uh
didn't go over well so casey if you
don't mind let's just queue that up and
play it right now so you people can
decide for yourself
you can recite pi to 200 decimals that's
nice but you look like a geek so who
gives a [ __ ] if you wanna get laid you
know when the club start reciting pie to
a hoe it's the worst game i've ever seen
reciting pie to a hoe now obviously this
is just objectively funny because andrew
tate is [ __ ] on a 12 year old or 11.
hey who are you giving hate of the week
to
oh um
i was actually going to give it to
brendan and brian for hating on this
andrew tate clip uh
interesting i didn't know you were even
going to be here that's
um i'll be right back i'm gonna go tell
brandon no don't do that dude jay i
thought we were cool what the
dude you think you're friends with
somebody and then they just
did you tell him i was gonna do this
well no but i did see him standing there
which i thought was alarming oh my and i
didn't even see i guess my peripherals
are a little bit off because i can't
it's like i was so hyper focused on this
andrew tate video in just my career in
general that i couldn't even see what
was in my blonde spot which was a snake
in the grass ratting me out it's like i
was gonna tell brendan to do his head of
the week i just didn't get around to it
yet anyway
this brings up a more interesting
conversation
about andrew tate and um
there's so much to pick apart however i
just wanted to take one little thing
that i've been noticing when people
discuss androtate
the one phrase and maybe case you can
already think of this but here's what
they'll phrase any any time andrew take
comes up in conversation guys go i don't
agree with everything he says
before anything that he said has
actually been discussed to go i don't
agree with everything he says
now
if you agree with everything another
person says to me that would be the
problem right i hope you guys don't
agree with everything that i say
you know like when i say i micro dose
mushrooms this morning i hope not
everybody is doing that but you know if
that works for you
i hope that you're doing it now i am
putting this screenshot up here because
a friend of mine a guy named connor
my freshman your roommate at pomona
college who's very intelligent he's
a marine corps officer so he was a jag
lawyer in the marine corps after he went
to law school he recently graduated busy
went to notre dame law school he went to
georgetown business school so he's an
accomplished academic
in the sense that he's made it through
school not that he has phd and
writes dissertations or contributes to
the academic literature but he's a smart
guy who thinks now if we
scroll down that page just a little bit
more he goes have you heard this and
this is his interview with patrick bett
david which i do think is a good channel
and he has good interviews i think he's
a good
interviewer
um and has an eclectic perspectives on
there have you heard this he's so
interesting don't agree with him but
he's smart for sure and so i just went
out of my way to say what do you
disagree with him about and trying to
not come off as confrontational or
saying that i agree like before i watch
i haven't watched it but just let me
know
but i thought his response was
interesting um i def agree with his
perspective on free speech and i think
he's highly intelligent i think most of
my disagreement is likely more
on form than content he's so quick to
say brash wild [ __ ] sort of trump-like
but he's actually super intelligent so
when he's pushed on those points unlike
trump he responds with very intelligent
analysis on human nature so upon
reflection i'd mostly just disagree with
him
so far on style
and i think i'm a little more optimistic
about the virtues of human nature he's
deaf from the streets and has this
ruthless honest appraisal of human
nature i've never
heard him more than a 10 second clip i
never i never hear more than a 10 second
clip from him and he really surprised me
i love it when people surprised me and
at the end of the day i think conor
what i continue to love about him is the
fact that
he's very open-minded and positive while
also being actually this is a good
personality segue he's an estj
oftentimes i would butt heads with
people who are estjs because they're
very rule oriented they're very like
this is the way things should be done it
should be traditional it should be
according to a certain bureaucratic
process they want things organized um
you know you can imagine me and a person
like that living in
a six by six uh cell in college having
some conflict but we worked through it
um funny story i remember one time
i was taking a nap i had the worst sleep
when i was a freshman um
like i would
i had a job over the summer
that
i had to get up at like 4 a.m to go
train people at the ymca
a few days of the week and then the
other days i was trying to hang out with
my friends like my you know i'd like
stay up till three and then like wake up
at four and try to get on the schedule
on snapping the day and it just messed
me up for like literally like a year and
i didn't understand like how to get back
on this
now was i also taking nor andersen and
that might have been an issue too yes
but that's a separate discussion
um
because although i feel like those
things didn't work i feel like it
like messed with my temperament and
hormones potentially so even when things
don't work they can still mess up your
hormones
um
but one time
he had left this like reading lamp on
like a halogen lamp on
and left the room like he was studying
with it and i was trying to sleep now
this actually was at night it wasn't
during the day but
instead of turning it off i put his
sheet on top of it like i was like let
me just cover this with a comforter
because that's like you know that's less
rude somehow than actually just turning
off the person's lamp
um
and then
i woke to him coming back in the room
and also like you know the smell in the
air uh of a burning
uh lycra or whatever the hell it was
polyester
through the sheet and uh it's something
that he'll never let me forget
but i appreciate that because it was a
funny moment that you know could i like
i could have woken up to actual flames
like you know engulfing our dorm room
but i didn't we caught it just in time
crazy kids doing their thing
so
that's what i have to say as far as
conor on andrew tate and i agree that
it's an interesting thing where somebody
becomes controversial or they become
canceled or you know
even the way that we use language about
him instead of saying
like
you know i
whatever i agree with him on this people
say well i don't agree with everything
right it's like this big cautionary move
and then
when pressed on it
now i think that's a more reasonable
stance to take is that he doesn't like
his
style essentially so
as far as
the points he
makes he's like i'm more optimistic
about human nature but as far as like
the main issue that he has is the
delivery and like with that video or
whatever um
i thought it was funny because obviously
being sarcastic or over the top to a
degree and it's like a commentary on
like
if you were just watching that clip in
isolation you'd be like oh this guy is a
dumb ass or he's a thug or he hates kids
or something like that but it's like
it's a kernel of truth that's
exaggerated i know he doesn't actually
feel that way about kids but it's just
so surprising to hear somebody like rip
an 11 year old for
memorizing
pi to 200 decimal places because we
don't normally hear that everything is
applauded so i think it's funny to [ __ ]
on kids sometimes
is the takeaway from the segment now can
we go on
to
geriatric lifting achievements this is a
new segment here
and uh this is me and brian at the
studio yesterday
and
you know
i let my buddy todd borrow this hundred
pound kettlebell during the pandemic
it's something that i bought and you too
can go on walmart they're super cheap
and there's like free to leave you sign
up for like walmart whatever
you know
online membership they send you these
things for free with free shipping so
you can get a hundred pound kettlebell
for like a dollar a pound so i don't
think this is much more than a hundred
pounds and it's super versatile now a
lot of people oh my god 100 pound
kettlebell it's so heavy
but is it though because as you can see
here
a 90 year old man is lifting it with one
arm and i made sure that this was a safe
setup
um i'm not asking him to like do a
kettlebell swing with it or one arm
snatch or something like that
i'm just saying brace yourself
against this post here
uh get an athletic stance so your
weight's not too much out over your
knees and row it up like that and i
think he surprised himself and that i
thought was worth sharing because
you guys
if you're out there going oh i can't
lift that now some lifts obviously don't
push yourself too hard on like you know
if you can't deadlift 500 pounds there's
not a huge benefit to doing that but
something like a kettlebell right a
hundred pounds maybe you're okay brian's
what
170 pounds
it
to him it seemed like a lot but i'm like
but your back is extremely strong
you can you can in fact lift that you
can in fact challenge yourself so if
you're somebody who's conservative
when it comes to lifting i would
encourage you to find
safe modes of lifting
you know um almost like like you know
a weighted pull-up it's like oh my god i
couldn't do a weighted pull-up with 45
pounds around my waist like i can do 10
try it what's the worst that can happen
with a weighted pull-up you're not going
to pull a bicep unlike
curling an excessive amount of weight
where the uh
you know there's so much tension on that
moment arm that you actually could
injure yourself
a heavy pull-up's pretty safe a heavy
dip is actually pretty safe um
you know a a
even a dead lift with a kettlebell
because
you're going to have to lift that sumo
style with a more wrecked back it's
going to be a lot safer so
i'm saying this to encourage you because
my mom can deadlift 92 pounds uh i i
have my onyx kettlebell that i left with
her specifically so she can do this
exact form of lifting
uh maybe not a one arm
uh row but she can in fact
dead lift it for reps so you can let my
mom beat you is that what you gonna do
huh you gotta my 72 year old mom be
stronger than you i don't think so so if
you're scared uplifting
come on show me you're stronger than
evelyn you know maybe at this point in
the podcast you're asking yourself mark
is kratom and micro dosing mushrooms a
dangerous mixture to which i'll answer
of course not obviously it's safe
because i'm doing that right now and if
you wanted to get kratom for yourself to
mix with your mushroom powder however
you
procured that for yourself none of my
business obviously
i would go to happy
happyhippoherbles.com
and use promo code thick boy with 3cs
for 20
off
you can mix you can match you can do
whatever you want as long as you use
responsibly but i guarantee you order
once you're going to be coming back
especially if you're comparing to other
websites out there as far as quality
there's just no competitor happy hippo
herbals.com promo code big boy for 20
off for the rest of your life and
hopefully your life gets elongated when
we figure out how to annihilate those
pesky p16 proteins without inducing
cancer you know i've decided this is my
favorite oakenstone shirt
out of all the things that i have it's
versatile
it's uh i like the cut of it i think i
just looked the best in it to be honest
with you okay and this is like a scoop
neck long sleeve
black with a little pocket here just in
case i want to have a pen or something
like that
but the material is fantastic
i've
been telling you how good oakenstone
clothing is for quite some time now and
a lot of you took advantage of it last
month and i'm still catching up with all
the people who
bought things and i'm gonna get on the
phone hopefully this weekend if not
early next week i will have gone through
every single last person and i'm also
thinking of a new promotion to do
this month for the end of september
i just don't know what it is yet okay
it's going to be something cool i want
to offer something of value to you that
you could actually
use so maybe that's a workout plan
maybe that's a nude photograph of me
just kidding guys that would be crazy
but if you have ideas put them in the
comments or dm me directly because i
want to offer something you
unique and special
kind of like
oak and stone clothing so if you go to
oakenstoneclothing.com and use promo
code hella for 10 off at checkout and
then dm me with something that you would
like on top of that
maybe we can make it a reality what do
we got next oh i know
how to stop aging
i thought this was super interesting if
you started at 2 30
this is like just you know one of these
little mind blowing i like watching
stuff like this and just
going damn i'm stupid
um
if you don't mind playing this
one way to tackle aging is to prevent or
inhibit senescence
that's when our cells stop growing and
replicating and kind of become zombie
cells when you're young your immune
system clears them out easily zombies
are bad guys the number of senescent
cells increase in our immune system its
function decreases so you get this
tipping point where you start having too
many senescent cells not enough
functional immune cells these senescent
cells bombard nearby cells releasing
chemicals that break down connective
tissue and trigger inflammation which is
the root cause of many age-related
diseases like cancer alzheimer's and
heart disease yeah so can we just get
rid of those senescent cells in 2016 a
team of scientists did just that in mice
senescent cells contained the protein
p16 scientists were able to create a
drug that targets p16 specifically
killing senescent cells in the process
the mouse that received the drug was
faster and stronger until the last few
months before death its life was about a
quarter longer and it was also healthier
that discovery spawned a whole new
chapter of research called senalytics
treatments that clean out those
senescent cells
everybody's jumped into this space
google in collaboration with abbvie
started a company called caligo and put
billions of dollars into developing
drugs for healthy aging that says yes
people are believing that this is
possible there's a catch here though the
p16 protein is also responsible for
suppressing tumors
if we're clearing out these senescent
cells regularly it could trigger tumor
and cancer growth we are
not sure of the long-term impacts yet
okay i think that's probably enough so
if you suppress the p16
then you might uh not be able to control
cancer growth or tumor growth so
that's it there always seems to be like
this trade-off you know an immune or
even with like growth hormone is
anti-aging but uh some protests that
i've heard from people even talking to
brian callan he was like oh i won't take
it because you know when you're
encouraging growth of new cells like
that you're also
incurring a potential risk for cancer or
tumor growth now i don't know if that
has played out in actuality like an
actual reality are people
experiencing an increased risk of cancer
or is it just theoretical with regards
to growth hormone but at the same time
um
you know it's just something to think
about that trade-off uh because you know
another element of it is like what's the
opposite of the growth hormone pathway
the growth pathways autophagy and
uh
you can't be doing both at the same time
and so there's a lot of health benefits
from both but you can't be doing both at
the same time you can't be you know
cleaning away all those dead cells and
having your body eat itself while also
on this you know growth hormone pathway
so there's something similar there i
thought it was really interesting but
you know
also worth noting is just the fact that
so many diseases come from inflammation
and i was also watching another video
that we talked about last week um
you know exercise on the hierarchy of
things like you know compared to
supplements and stuff like that and
exercise is one of these things that uh
reduces
or helps you know essentially combat
almost every disease so whether we're
talking about cancer heart disease any
form of of inflammation even though it
might temporarily increase your
inflammation in the body over time it
does help your body
regulate inflammation
and and combat it in the long term even
if it might increase it in the short
term due to muscular damage so just
something to think about i love stuff
like this
because uh you know it gives me hope
that i'm going to live to 200 all right
that's that's why i'm doing it now
speaking of
aging prematurely went to wisconsin
and
god damn wisconsin loves their fried
food and i start to see
i start to have a lot of empathy for
the fact that
uh you know
this is another discussion i wanted to
have where you know you go
a message like andrew tate has or or any
sort of
guy in the manosphere they're
essentially saying
it's up to you it's your responsibility
take life by the horns that george
jordan peterson and andrew tate whoever
this role model that you're looking
towards as a guy and you know the secret
to
um why these guys become popular it's
like this radical individual approach to
life because that's all you have control
over right it's the opposite of taking a
victim mentality now on the other side
of that if you wanted to look at a
broader
uh macro picture of what causes things
like obesity well you are in a society
and in a neighborhood or in a state or a
city or a culture
in which you're being told that
everything should be fried and that's
okay and don't question this so i just
thought it was an interesting because
compared to something like california
there just seems to be more healthy
options available and everywhere we went
it was like you know
okay your options on the menu are cheese
curds jalapeno poppers and it wasn't
just like at the bar it was like at the
restaurant you know it's like
everything's just fried food casey maybe
you've experienced this i know you're
not from
i'm not but i i've been there um and a
lot of like
places like it like uh when i worked on
the dan patrick show we would do a week
of shows leading up to the super bowl so
wherever the super bowl was
um that year that's where we would do
the shows from and a lot of places like
that where yeah you go out to eat and
it's like
it's gnarly yeah i mean it's delicious
it's amazing
it's it's it's fun but it's like that
was the first time i had cheese curds
and they are delicious and addictive and
um
very easy to eat but like yeah i would
gain like 15 pounds every super bowl
week yeah it's just one of these things
where i'm like i know i'm stupid for not
imagining this before because i you know
it's a cliche that people like eat a lot
of fried foods and but almost in my mind
it was like oh they're eating that at
the county fair or these fried butter
sticks are something that you like eat
when you're at this special occasion
what struck me was oh no this is a
regular occurrence this is something
you're inundated with and it's more work
to say you know look i remember coming
out of college and wanted to lose weight
for the first time
and
trying to tell just my mom like stop
making this italian food for me right i
don't want pasta and raviolis and you're
a wonderful cook and you make amazing
things that you learned from your mother
but please don't offer it for me
and it was so difficult you know both
for me to like
just push it away not eat it because
when you're presented with something
that's like
part of your upbringing this comfort
food or whatever it is
uh it's very difficult to say i'm not
going to do this like it's because
everything around you is going to know
it's fine it's totally fine it's only in
your mind and so i empathize
with that struggle where everybody
around you is going no no it's totally
cool to eat the fried food or eat the
pasta or go off your diet in some way
because you have a different vision for
yourself and a different goal
and then also for my mom which i have a
lot of empathy for but i remember
getting angry i'm like why can't you
just not do this but it's like
it's ingrained in her hard drive too to
be like this is an expression of my love
and caring of course i'm cooking for you
and meat is asking
don't do that anymore it's sort of like
asking your mom hey don't love me
anymore right it's very difficult for
them so that was like on a micro level
of like just in my household
i could hardly deal with this and
eventually i did but i just remember
that was like i'm like ah this
unanticipated struggle of like
overcoming the things that are around
you like sure if i
lived in a vacuum and you know i could
just like type into a computer here's
the amount of food you know like anybody
can lose weight if you just like lived
in a jail cell
and uh you had somebody deliver
1500 calories to you every day that's
your only choice is to eat this stuff or
starve so of course you're gonna lose
weight but in the real world we have to
reckon
with all these different variables
including the forces both
uh you know familial and societal
telling you dude it's okay be like us
right because nobody's criticizing you
so in that instance you just have to fat
shame yourself you fat piece of [ __ ]
uh stop eating pasta now
is that it you know i was always going
to say i'm sick this week and you know i
haven't i worked out on the road i
worked out on friday and saturday and
then what is it now
um thursday good god i have not worked
out no i did work out a little bit with
brendan on
um tuesday but other than that i've been
sleeping in and i'm just gonna announce
it that i'm okay with that and i
like when you're sick sometimes it's
okay to just go like
yeah i feel like sleeping a little bit
more and i've done that now i don't plan
on doing that forever so it is a mental
battle of like oh my god should i sleep
until 8 am
yes when you're an adult and you have
things to do that is a long time to
sleep in or if i'm getting up earlier
than that normally to go work out it's
it is
a battle with yourself where you're
telling yourself that your fat lazy
piece of [ __ ] now in my case i actually
am but
hopefully that's temporary okay i
couldn't even tell you were sick by the
way you always come in with like 100
energy 100 positivity i couldn't tell
you were sick really yeah thanks dayquil
dayquil mushrooms uh diet cokes rain
body exactly yes brought to you by you
know uh the double dose of i literally
do just take like right off the bat i
take a double dose of dayquil i'm like i
can't this is meant for 110 pound person
i'm 2.5 or whatever 2.25
um
you'll be totally fine but i also okay i
remember this funny story when i was
also a freshman in college
my this guy across the street
who i ended up becoming friends with but
at first he was like projecting on to me
that i was like this homophobic football
player and he was a gay dude and um i
remember he used to like avoid me i'm
like why does this guy like avoid him in
the hallways
but you know just because i beat up one
gay dude like in the street and he saw
that it's like dude like he was you know
kissing another dude in front of me
obviously i'm kidding stop don't take
that out of context to ruin my career
but
i'll remember this now like if dave was
here i would say this in front of him i
remember when he got sick one time and
he literally seemingly went through
every person in his rolodex and was like
oh my god i'm so sick today
i have a cold oh like and i'd have to
hear the same conversation like 30 times
and i'm like oh my god like not everyone
has to know that you're sick
and so that was a lesson to me of
how boring it is to hear other people
like to to hear another human talk about
how sick they are so from that point on
i just feel like
if you're gonna make it like a big mopey
deal like you might as well just call in
sick and stay home which i love doing i
love calling in sick but sometimes the
cold isn't quite worth it now the
question on everybody's mind
that i wrote up
here in the morning
i've been thinking about should i get
into swimming again i wanted brenda and
i have talked about doing a triathlon
and i actually
i want to do it i used to swim
competitively in high school and i was
thinking about joining
uh
the local pool
is that weird i don't know but i want to
chase some of these
like prs that i had as a high school
student i feel like that in some ways
might be equally or more gratifying than
the weightlifting stuff that i've been
doing because also i look at myself and
go like i'm not going to get that much
stronger
you know like i'm not going to chase you
know as i
approach 50 i'm not going to be like i
want a 700 pound deadlift or something
you know like that like i've deadlifted
500 pounds
i've wrapped
uh you know high 300s i just don't have
the desire to like prove that i can do
certain feats of strength and i think
it's more impressive
to myself probably because i remember
doing swimming workouts and being like
this is the worst pain of my life i hate
everything about this and i think
that's what i want to conquer like
that's what i want to go back and be
like no you can do this
and
also when i was swimming i was comparing
myself to other people who like swam you
around and so they're just in better
shape than even though i might have been
faster than some of the people who were
like whooping my ass in practice
i still compared myself with like it was
unusually painful i'm like how are they
getting through this whole thing like i
have to get up and pee in the middle of
you know did you ever swim casey no lame
but you know it's it's it's more akin to
like a crossfit workout you know i mean
maybe the first time you go to crossfit
workout you're like jesus christ how is
everybody doing this i also think
psychologically like when you're at
practice you have to do it so it sucks
right you're like [ __ ] i have to do this
i have to get through practice whereas
now if you were to do it you're choosing
to do it so you're almost reframing the
exercise yes
right yeah there wasn't this incentive
of like i like
it was the same way that i started to
view school i remember
like
like
it was like how do i get through this
rather than like there's an inherent
benefit to being excellent yeah you know
and like proving this to yourself and
um that's how i already feel about
weightlifting it's like it's not for
anybody but me i'm not like trying to
cheat some weightlifting coach into
thinking that i'm doing better than i
did but i used to like try to find ways
to get like just survive this
uh swimming workout because i felt like
it was impossible for me to do it like
as planned and that may have been the
case like because again if you're in way
better shape
um
and also
training for some remember being like
okay so
you know i'm doing a you know a 50-yard
freestyle like why am i swimming at 200
what's the point of that you know it's
like a power lifter you're training for
one rep and this guy has got you doing
you know 25 reps said it didn't make
sense to me and i trust the process
come on you sound like him exactly
in practice why would
so when i show up all tan and with my
hair shaved you know what time it is
daddy um next up on the hello
personality portion of the podcast i
just wanted to do a brief bit on s
versus n types because i was talking the
other day with isaiah as we're going
through his apartment he was like
um
[Music]
mark makes the same mistake every time
he gets off the elevator he goes to the
right and i'm like you're absolutely
right because i don't pay attention to
any of my surroundings wherever i go
unless i'm forced to unless like you're
like mark you're leading this adventure
then i would panic and like go on google
maps to find out where apartment 214 is
but outside of that i simply
i'm so quick to daydream
and the guy who we were with
uh his name's nap he's been shooting
some of the sketches from me and isaiah
he was like oh i'm the same way and then
i'm like oh my little brother
and isaiah are like like isaiah's like
i've always been able to like
mark things in my head and i remember my
little brother would do that like better
than anyone in our family and it turns
out they both are s types now i think
this is an important distinction because
it might be one of the biggest
differences and one of the you know
people know introversion versus
extroversion but s versus n types it
says so much about you and if you scroll
up a little bit i just want to read the
first part yeah
our second personality scale and they
call it intuitive versus observance so n
is the intuitive observant is s these
traits describe what people are more
likely to do with the information
gathered from the world around them
intuitive personality types rely on
imagining the past and future potential
of what they see
so i very quickly slip into imagination
land
and in that imagination land i am rich
and successful and younger than i am in
reality
those with the observant style are more
interested in observable facts and more
straightforward outcomes they prefer to
avoid layering too much interpretation
on what they see so there are pitfalls
to both of these things like you know
for example
um
if you're like even when coming up with
sketches sometimes like me and isaiah
are are a classic and an s type and
he'll have an idea like he has a really
good way of being like i know exactly
what it needs to be it's got to be like
under a minute um you know we're going
to do it like this other thing that i've
seen it's inspired by this and like i
know how to shoot it and i'm kind of
like well what if we made it meta and
like broke the fourth wall and like made
it three minutes long and like
everything's like a hat on a hat and a
hat and it's like you want a little bit
of that but i can quickly go to
crazyville and then it's like cool like
who's gonna shoot this million dollar
budget sketch that you just came up with
versus isaiah is like no i we can do
this with one camera and like we don't
even need a cameraman i'm gonna shoot it
like this so
as far as like getting things done
the opposite of my personality is ideal
[Laughter]
but um
the trap there is also like
then
thinking outside the box you know it
means so
now i think both types can do this it's
just like that's my go-to and that does
come in handy
but
you know not all the time it's not
always the best thing so i like i think
you should be able to like do both you
should practice whatever you're weak at
and then also play to your strength and
know that is your strength and know
that's how you can like market yourself
or like oh i'm this guy now i can do
both styles if forced to
91 of those with the intuitive trade say
they like to discuss different views and
theories of what the world could look
like in the future compared to 55
percent with the observant trait being
intuitive doesn't mean somebody can't be
practical and being observant doesn't
mean a lack of imagination they both use
their minds and their physical senses as
well the difference is the spin they put
on their experiences it's with their
thinking goes uh it's where their
thinking goes after an encounter with
their environment if intuitive
personality types appreciate observant
types practicality an observant
personality type appreciates intuitive
types imaginative to perspective they
can complement each other in ways that
make for unbeatable partnerships and so
that's what we're actually observing and
i always have gone out of my way like
this is the crux of why i think the mbti
has been useful for me is
when like an istj goes we should do it
like this because that's actually the
right way to do it younger me might be
like
fu like i want to do it my way and you
know doing it backwards and upside down
is the cooler way to do it and you're
attacking me personally
by
suggesting that we do it the right way
but sometimes the right way is just the
right way and as i've said before
it's a matter of anxiety for them where
they go oh there's just a lot of risk
and not doing in the right way or the
most efficient way or the most linear
way
um 59 of those with the observant trait
say they prefer art that has a clear
theme message a meaning over art that is
uh or meaning over art that is vague and
leaves too much to interpretation
compared to 38 of those with the
intuitive trait and i love crazy art too
but also
like
i think
there's a huge value in making something
classic that's really well done so i
think that is like
a you know
something that i've come to appreciate
is something that's simplistic and
classic but done to a super excellent
level people with the intuitive trait
prefer to exercise their imagination as
they seek new ideas and possibilities
yes new ideas and possibilities it's
just that if you get caught up in that
oh it's going to be
you know you can think of possibilities
all day and never end up getting to
anything
um they live their day-to-day you know
is there anything else interesting here
as i'm looking at the possibilities of
this web page
um
i think that's about it we'll come back
to this
you know but
i think it's important to know which
type you are and when i for example when
i start talking about personality type
to somebody and they get really
interested in it i know they're an end
type because to an s type it's like
boring like who are the actual people
what what actual people are we talking
about i don't want to talk about the
theory of 16 different personality types
that's boring until i actually meet the
person i want to go out and meet and
know
what this person is and maybe catego
catalog that in my mind but i don't need
to
like sit there and jerk off about the
theory of it
i want to jerk off in front of that
person
okay so a lot of people have been asking
me
somebody asked me yesterday these are
two stairway questions um
i'm also going to try to get optimal
test levels any advice
before i go in or what to ask for
and
my answer was what you want to say is
you go to the doctor and say hello can i
have steroids
and he says haha well that's
uh the approach i was going to go with
but i don't know if that would be
frowned upon i said are you in the us he
says no up in australia okay okay so
since you're in australia the technique
i'd recommend is going to the doctor
saying i can't look my i've been wanting
to get big like hitler mike harley can
you prescribe me some of the testicle
juice extract nice
and that's just the absolute
got him of it all
never again shall he question me okay
help i'm on steroids two people this
week have given me this last minute like
okay i'm gonna go through this one and
then i'm gonna go through another one
where i'm like guys like okay first of
all i know some stuff about anabolics i
don't know how to like cheat tests all
right what's good harley uh i have a
blood test tomorrow to hop on the trt
train good for you i've been looking if
and how you should try and lower your
test levels the day of the test but it
seems to be a lot of conflicting
information any advice on if you should
try and lower your levels before testing
if so what actually works like if that's
your desire to like because i guess most
guys like they're not looking at it as a
medical issue like oh my god i'm like
wondering what's happening oh my god i
have no test it's like they're kind of
like
i want to get on test therefore
like how do i manipulate my results to
get that and that's why i'm always like
just figure out the dark web and then
just do it it's going to be a lot
cheaper that's that would be my approach
to things but again i'm an n type and
you might not be you want to follow the
rules
um and i'm like by tomorrow not sure
don't sleep drink alcohol now those are
certifications but at the same time
those
uh might work right drinking alcohol not
getting enough sleep these are classic
things that if you came to me and told
me like i'm not getting any gains and
i'm like well what are you doing i'm not
sleeping every night i'm drinking
alcohol that would suppress your test
right
casey do you have any idea of how to
suppress your testosterone
no i don't [ __ ] ah
like as uh alpha male chad who
constantly has high testosterone i just
wouldn't even it's not something that
i've ever had to concern myself with now
the second guy
i don't have the screenshot i looked for
but sometimes you know i just i'm such a
popular instagrammer who posts so many
memes that people put heart reactions to
that these messages get lost in the fray
but he hits me up and i feel bad because
he was like i was consulting him
about getting on test and uh before the
the season and yada yada and i felt like
oh here i am doing my due diligence but
then he comes to me he's like i'm
getting tested tomorrow from the ncaa
like how do i get out of this and i'm
like dude i don't know like you know i i
sent him a link for the wizonator so you
can have a fake [ __ ] to pee in this cup
but he's like well it's kind of like
tomorrow i need it i'm like ah i don't
know you need to give me a lot more
information as far as like is somebody
literally going to watch your dong as
you pee
sounds kind of hot i don't know um
but he
like i wanted to like are you sure
you're going to be tested is the whole
team going to be tested it's going to be
randomly selected is it going to be for
is it just for weed or other drugs is it
definitely for steroids because that is
a different test right so
i want to help people but also like this
is not my expertise there are however
things online there are experts online
that can help you navigate these
situations but the most important thing
to be like if you're for example if you
came out you're like oh my parents are
drug testing me because i got caught
smoking weed i wouldn't assume
that
that test also includes like a battery
of anabolics and even when you're doing
testosterone
my understanding is that
they have more sophisticated tests that
can detect exogenous testosterone in and
of itself but
the less sophisticated tests
are testing your ratio of testosterone
to epi testosterone and there's actually
a pretty big
margin there so if you were to beat the
test versus saying like
you know i remember taking an angelo and
being like wow if they tested me like
this is in your system for 18 months now
testosterone they can't measure that
same or at least they couldn't when i
was taking it uh back in the day and
might have been tested and that's just
an easy one to be just stop taking it if
you know you're going to be tested but
again i just felt bad because it was
like i felt like i put somebody in this
situation and that's not necessarily
true but like
you just if you want to do this you know
there's a chance you're gonna get tested
like be an internet sleuth go online
um buy a fake dong that's all i gotta
say or you can do the jon jones method
oh yeah just hide under the cage
you're under the camera bleacher for 12
hours i mean there's got to be ways
around right like even just to buy
yourself like like you know if you're
like oh my god there's an emergency like
you know my grandma like you can think
of something so that's why i wanted like
as much information from this kid as
possible to be like what are we dealing
with exactly i want to help you
strategize but like even the difference
between
are you you know i remember beating like
because i
was smoking weed at a time i got this
like hotel job and
they made you go get a drug test well
you just go to the doctor's office or
whatever and you like go into a room
and i have this like fake piss powder
that you put water in you ever done that
before because you've never done drugs
in your life no well
it's funny because i don't smoke weed
but i've had uh i'm probably like the
only one of my friends who doesn't yeah
and so i've been the clean piss oh yeah
so
even having this like container in my
i'm like if this guy like pats down my
cargo shorts he's going to find the fake
piss powder in my pockets
so
uh
bigger issue is you wearing cargo you
got to get that figured out first then
was this part of my repertoire in 2013
or was this just like oh good thing i
didn't throw away these cargo shorts
let's just go with that even though it's
probably
the uh the former so
but that worked totally fine and um you
know i remember him taking my blood
pressure and i was super nervous about
he's like blood pressure a little spiked
i'm like i don't know where that could
possibly come from definitely not for me
faking this drug test to get this
bellhop job um
but you know if that is the difference
like if they allow you to go in a room
and like pee then that's the world of
difference versus even standing behind
you because having a fake dong like
you could stand up with a cup and it
sounds like it versus like just like
like splashed in there it's like well
that was an interesting sound for
somebody peeing out of a tiny urethra
but
um you know these things make the i know
in like the the uh
in the olympics they probably like
actually look at your penis which is
super weird right to think about you're
like no seriously could you not look
directly at my genitals as i pee i'm a
grower not a shower
uh let's get on to this while we can't
have nice jobs
[Laughter]
but to the uh to the fans of haters will
say if you need clean piss just message
mark i'll be happy to send you some piss
you know
um i'll have casey pissing a cop and
it's just a totally normal uh chain of
uh transaction here you know you asked
me i asked kc he pees i take it
i do whatever i want with it before
getting it to you there might be a delay
of a few days
okay
the first one oh yeah me my socially
awkward ass wondering if i should ask
for a spot or just risk it it's jay
cutler looking gigantic you forget how
big some of these like the olympia level
bodybuilders were
um and also his face is so gigantic too
like look at how big his chin and jaw is
like that's one thing where i'm like
when i get bigger i'm like
my face isn't that big compared to the
rest of my body to support all of this
mass i have a normal to small sized face
so
if i get any bigger it just looks like i
have a tiny head and guys
don't have tiny head syndrome all right
also this reminds me buddy todd he's
always hitting 315 on bench or incline
and he's always complaining about how
people [ __ ] up his spot he's like oh my
god this guy touched it yet i'm like
then don't use a spot because then guess
what you can either hit 315 on incline
or die the choice is yours
now are we still in 2022 and people are
snapping rubber bands on their cooters
why yes we are but here's an explanation
for why this happened because she looks
like she's trying to kip she's like you
know she's in one of these black box
crossfit gyms and i think you see you
see what i'm saying i'm like now is this
funny or not should i post this yes it
is because
instead of just
putting
her foot all the way down and putting
pressure on there and keeping it stable
in order to assist her she seemingly
goes for a kipping pull-up
which results in
rubber on the vajayjay yeah the veg and
it's all hurt maybe that's a thing of
crossfit where it's like she can't
un learn that movement pattern right so
that's just yet another downside of
keeping pull-ups this guy is like
security cam footage he's got a
kettlebell
practicing
what is that motion a hammer throw i
guess right
but he's indoors it's like what did you
expect to happen so he's like oh my god
what the kettlebell that i threw hit
something in this indoor gym that's so
crazy and unexpected
um
and it looks pretty heavy like it
doesn't like fly out of his hands it
wouldn't surprise me if it's like i
don't know maybe i'm totally wrong but
he [ __ ] something up in that gym for
sure and he's uh it's funny because he's
like 300 pounds and he's like probably
walks around that gym like he owns a
place until he destroys one of the
lighting fixtures
now look i posted this the other day i
love beetlejuice memes this is the
funniest thing
uh beetlejuice from the howard stern
show says me walking into work knowing i
bench pressed more than all of my boss
is therefore i technically legally own
the company now i just posted that and
then somebody goes what about brendan
and i'm like okay you're gonna ruin all
my fun
by pointing out that brendan bench
presses more than me any other company
this would work you guys any other
company but thick boy studios
okay and now there's a little video
where this guy is like doing a sort of
[ __ ] squat motion where he's focusing
on his quads it's not illegitimate right
he's going all the way down somebody
puts a metal water bottle under his ass
now it's funny and all but i swear it
made me think if i was there squatting
and somebody put like a metal object
under my [ __ ] i would be furious
i'd say fair play i say like if
this video was me and it ended with me
just attacking whoever was in the
nearest proximity to me
you'd be like well mark said it on
haters will say don't try to break his
ass while he's because when you're
working out like what is that
you're like
i just as i've probably explained before
a lot of my silliness leaves my body
when i'm in a gym and i get i'm like i
will get irritated with people like
making jokes or being silly with me
at the gym because i'm like this is not
the time of the place with it and then
i'm like mark you're a huge hypocrite
because in 99 of your outside life
you're trying to inject silliness and
waste other people's time and now all of
a sudden when it comes to muscles you
don't want to mess around but that's
just my personal preference so i know i
look at that and go like i if somebody
like my gym partner or one of my friends
did that like
i might get so mad that i'd have to
leave the gym you know because i'm like
i'm going to be violent with somebody um
and i'm just gonna but i'm gonna remove
myself i'm not gonna act out i'm going
to remove myself switch gyms move cities
and that's the end of mark harley at la
fitness
when you're struggling to get that last
rep but you remember other dudes have
felt her nose against their waist
now casey what does that sound like to
you
um
like um she may be like sucking a wiener
like sucker
something like that
just a little
right
now i don't know i've never had that as
guys always talk about this you never
had your wiener sucked
yes no i've never had i don't know what
a nose feels like against there it's
just too big um
i've never had that like actual
motivation of being like
this girl broke my heart and i'm using
that for the gym maybe because i'm
motivated in different ways um you know
like being a closet homosexual really
goes a long way
like that you know this trumps
everything um so in that case your nose
would be able to wait so again yeah that
remain when you remember my nose was
against his stomach
um
but uh yeah apparently that's pretty
remember when you remember some other
dude has their nose against his stomach
right now
um okay this is like
is funny but it's also sad a 12 year old
did this because his mom took his phone
if you can see this video right now
it looks like a demolition crew came in
here and like
it's it's at first glance i'm like oh
this crazy video like i want to go back
and then i
watched it again like i flipped to
another video
and i came back and i just wanted to
include this
um
because
if you play the the
sound like you can hear the woman's
voice like oh my god like she's like
crying it's like yeah the kid destroyed
her entire house but also
like i go now that probably wasn't like
the first time you've had a discipline
issue right it wasn't the first time
you knew that this phone was an issue
and i remember you know like kids freak
out when you take their video games or
whatever
um
but
like
i just i wanted to show this because
this is what happens if like for example
if somebody took my kettlebell away you
know like this
this hundred pound kettlebell right here
if you were to take this away okay if
you tried taking this [ __ ] bad boy
away at any time i will
take it back
and then destroy the entire thick boy
studio with this hundred cow pound
kettlebell that you can't hide from me
because me and this hundred pound
kettlebell are linked at the soul do you
understand me so don't even try it it's
not funny it's not a good joke you will
end up getting your entire studio
destroyed understand thank you
you